[Music]
our 8 news now investigators getting a
response from Washington tonight we
thank you for joining us here at six I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftus that
report found no government agency nor
the railroad that runs trains right
through the middle of Las Vegas could
say exactly what's on them eight news
now investigator David charns here with
what our elected leaders say they're
doing about it David well last week at
11 we told you about 1200 miles of train
tracks run through Nevada but the city
of Las Vegas says it's not told what's
on those trains that you've probably
seen run right through town and Clark
County's emergency plans if there is a
derailment or an emergency say to call a
phone number about specific shipments
those train tracks like I just said go
right through the middle of the valley
the railroad and the federal government
say they're carrying things like
chemicals chlorine crude oil fertilizer
but nobody could tell us exactly what is
in them instead leaders at Union Pacific
the railroad company say if there's an
emergency responders have access to all
that information in an app even the
Federal Railroad Administration says
that what the trains are carrying is
proprietary Democratic senator Catherine
Cortez masto saw our story and today I
asked her if this is acceptable
what do you think the federal government
can do to make sure that everyone who
needs to know is aware of what is on
those trains there's legislation there
now really to start having hearings and
and ask these questions where's the
transparency where's the accountability
what should it look like yes we want to
preserve National Security we want to
protect a business's proprietary
information but at the same time we also
have to balance that with keeping our
community safe
so part of that plan to keep our
community safe is a plan making its way
through Congress right now to further
improve safety and regulate what these
trains are carrying democratic
congresswoman Dita Titus also responding
to our reporting of course she
represents the strip and those tracks
you saw there she says in part A spill
of dangerous materials would be
disastrous in terms of human and
financial costs she adds I will continue
to work with my colleagues on Common
Sense solutions to prevent more
derailments and toxic exposure incidents
like we saw in East Palestine now we
have not seen something like that here
on the state level of plan to regulate
the length of railroads and sensors on
tracks is moving forward representative
for the railroad saying the federal
government is the appropriate regulatory
agency to do that we'll keep you posted
on this story I'm David charns eight
news now Brian David thanks for that
that state proposal would limit trains
to less than 7 500 feet that is more
than a mile long it passed the assembly
it is now in the state senate